una comedia sobre dos personajes tristes
en busca del amor y un drama sobre el
radicalismo dietético entraron en Lisa
por el premio a la mejor película en
cannes
[Música]
el finlandés es candidato por quinta vez
a la palma de oro con las hojas muertas
la historia de dos Solitarios en busca
del amor en helsinski
en tierra
[Música]
naranja como la mayoría de los
personajes de carismaki los
protagonistas de esta cinta pertenecen a
la clase Obrera están inmersos en una
vida rutinaria y Modesta y un día se
encuentran por casualidad en un bar de
karaoke de la capital e intentan
convencerse de que Podrían haber
encontrado al fin el amor esta comedia
inexpresiva parece que sucediera en los
años 70 pero kaurismaki se las arregló
para recordarnos en filigrana que Rusia
ha invadido a Ucrania
[Música]
la austriaca Jessica housner continúa su
exploración de las sociedades modernas y
su radicalismos en su última cinta Club
cero
[Música]
Club cero arranca en un exclusivo Liceo
que recibe a una nueva profesora de
alimentación consciente mis Novak
convence a sus alumnas de la necesidad
de no alimentarse lo que tendrá
repercusiones dice ella para el medio
ambiente y la economía global algunos
jóvenes se abandonan a estas enseñanzas
para integrar un selecto y misterioso
grupo llamado Club cero
Helen alright
con esta película Jessica housner
critica a los fanatismos absurdos según
la sociedad que fabrica gurus e
influencer que manipulan a su público
hasta convertirlos en seres irracionales
[Música]